>>> SO MORE NOW ON THE DEADLY
STANDOFF IN OHIO AFTER POLICE
SAY A MAN ARD WITH AN
AR-15-STYLE WEAPON TRIED TO
ENTER THE FBI CINCINNATI'S FIELD
OFFICE.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS BEARING
THE MAN'S NAME INCLUDE
POLITICALLY VIOLENT POSTS
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO GO TO GUN
AND PAWNSHOPS TO, QUOTE, GET
WHATEVER YOU NEED TO BE READY
FOR COMBAT.
WITH US NOW CNN SENIOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANALYST AND FORMER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
ANDREW McCABE AND PHIL MUDD IS
BACK WITH US AS WELL.
ANDY, I JUST WANT TO START WITH
YOU.
AGAIN, WE'RE STILL LEARNING MORE
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN OHIO, BUT
THERE ARE THESE POSSIBLE LINKS
TO EVERYTHING ELSE THAT HAS
HAPPENED THIS WEEK.
YOUR VIEW.
>> JOHN, IT'S JUST SUCH AN
INCREDIBLY POTENT EXAMPLE OF THE
STATE OF THE THREAT IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW AND HOW EASILY
THAT THREAT OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE CAN BE ACCESSED BY
DONALD TRUMP AND DIRECTED BY
HIM.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE SAW
YESTERDAY.
ASSUMING THE INVESTIGATION BEARS
OUT THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL'S
MOTIVE WAS, IN FACT, TO ATTACK
THE FBI, HE MADE STATEMENTS
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE SEARCH
WARRANT AT MAR-A-LAGO ON MONDAY.
SO, THIS IS WHAT
COUNTERTERRORISM EXPERTS AND
OBSERVERS AND FOLKS LIKE MYSELF
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR
MONTHS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS AN AMAZING
AMOUNT OF INFLUENCE OVER PEOPLE
WHO HARBOR THESE SORTS OF
BELIEFS WHEN HE BASELESSLY
FLOATS OUT AN ALLEGATION, AS HE
DID ON MONDAY, ABOUT THE FBI
POSSIBLY PLANTING EVIDENCE IN
HIS RESIDENCE, WHICH WE ALL KNOW
THERE'S BEEN ABSOLUTELY ZERO
PROOF PRODUCED FOR THAT.
HE KNOWS THAT THAT COULD HAVE
AN -- THAT CAN HAVE INCREDIBLY
INSPIRING EFFECT ON PEOPLE WHO
HARBOR THESE EXTREME BELIEFS AND
COMPEL THEM TO MOVE TO TAKE
VIOLENT ACTION.
IT IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
>> PHIL, HE IS NOT THE ONLY ONE,
RIGHT?
ALL OF THIS GETS AMPLIFIED.
YOU HEAR PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT HIM,
ELECTED OFFICIALS THE KIND OF
RHETORIC THAT THEY'RE USING.
WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS?
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE, AS THEY
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE WEAPONIZATION
OF THE DOJ AND THE FBI ARE IN A
WAY WEAPONIZING THAT RHETORIC.
>> MY MESSAGE IS PROFESSIONAL
AND INTENSELY PERSONAL AND THE
PROFESSIONAL PIECE, LET ME FOCUS
ON RADICALIZATION, WHETHER
YOU'RE DEALING WITH ISIS OR AL
QAEDA, DURING THE DAYS OF
ISLAMIC TERRORISM, ISIS AND AL
QAEDA, YOU NEEDED RADICALIZERS.
IF AN INDIVIDUAL WANTS TO COMMIT
AN ACT OF VIOLENCE, OFTEN
THERE'S A CASE OF SOMEONE THEY
RESPECT WHO WILL VALIDATE THAT
PERSON'S FEELING.
YOU'RE 18, YOU'RE 20, YOU'RE 25,
YOU'RE 30 ANGRY ABOUT AMERICA,
I'M TELLING YOU AS A RESPECTED
FIGURE YOU CAN USE VIOLENCE.
WE'RE SEEING THAT FROM THE
FRINGE TO A CORE MOVEMENT AMONG
FAR RIGHT CONSERVATIVES TELLING
PEOPLE THAT IT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE TO USE VIOLENCE FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
SO THIS IS ABOUT RADICALIZATION
THAT YOU WOULD SEE IN A LOT OF
TERROR CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I
WITNESSED.
LET ME CLOSE QUICKLY ON A
PERSONAL NOTE.
THIS MORNING I WOKE UP HAVING
RECEIVED THE MOST VICIOUS PIECE
OF PERSONAL HATE MAIL I HAVE
RECEIVED IN YEARS.
IT APPEARS FROM MY READING OF
THIS HATE MAIL THAT IT RESULTS
FROM SOMEONE WHO WAS RADICALIZED
BY WHAT THEY SAW US SAY,
INCLUDING ME, IN RESPONSE TO
WHAT HAPPENED IN MAR-A-LAGO AND
WHAT THAT PERSON IS SEEING THEIR
POLITICAL LEADERS SAY.
IF YOU THINK THIS ISN'T
SIGNIFICANT IN AMERICA, IT'S
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
AND IT IS COMPREHENSIVE,
BRIANNA.
WHEN PEOPLE TELL SOMEONE TO BE
RADICALIZED, PEOPLE WILL
RADICALIZE.
>> THIS NOTE THREATENED YOU,
YOUR LIFE, PHIL?
>> I GET A LOT OF HATE MAIL.
THIS IS BORDERLINE CRIMINAL
REFERRAL.
I WILL NOT REFER IT.
BUT THIS INDIVIDUAL TOLD ME I
NEED TO BE SMACKED AROUND AND
THAT I'M THE SCUM OF THE EARTH.
I WILL NOT GET INTO THE
ADDITIONAL PIECES OF THIS.
I GET THIS KIND OF STUFF PRETTY
REGULARLY, BUT THIS IS MORE
SIGNIFICANT THAN WHAT I HAVE
RECEIVED IN A WHILE.
AGAIN, FIRST QUESTION WAS
WHETHER IT GOES TO POLICE.
IT WON'T BECAUSE IT DOESN'T HAVE
SOME SPECIFICS I LOOK FOR, BUT
MAN, THIS IS EMBLEMATIC OF WHAT
WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY, JOHN.
>> ANDY, HOW MUCH RISK IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT DO YOU FEEL THAT FBI
PERSONNEL AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL ARE THIS
WEEK?
>> WELL, JOHN, THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THE WORK
ENVIRONMENT FOR FBI PEOPLE HAS
BEEN GETTING TOUGHER AND
TOUGHER.
TOUGHER OVER THE LAST FIVE OR
SIX YEARS, RIGHT?
SO, YOU KNOW, TRUMP HAS BEEN
BASICALLY AT WAR WITH THE FBI
SINCE WE OPENED A CASE ON HIS
CAMPAIGN IN JULY OF 2016.
THAT HAS A CORROSIVE EFFECT ON
THE ABILITY OF FBI AGENTS AND
PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT STAFF TO
DEVELOP THE SORT OF TRUST THAT
THEY NEED TO GET THEIR JOB DONE.
NOW WE'VE GONE ONE GIANT STEP
FURTHER THAN THAT.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE THIS PERSON
FROM CINCINNATI YESTERDAY ONLINE
TALKING ABOUT ACTIVELY TARGETING
FBI AGENTS AS THEY CONDUCT THEIR
WORK IN FIELD, AS THEY'RE OUT IN
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES TALKING
TO VICTIMS, TALKING TO
WITNESSES.
YOU HAVE THOUSANDS OF FBI PEOPLE
OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY EVERY
SINGLE DAY DOING THIS VITAL AND
IMPORTANT WORK.
AND NOW TO KNOW THAT THERE MAY
BE A CORE ELEMENT OF EXTREMISTS
REALLY ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
TARGETING THEM IS INCREDIBLY,
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
AND COULD I JUST ADD TO ADDRESS
BRIANNA'S QUESTION, MY QUESTION
FOR OUR POLITICAL LEADERSHIP OF
BOTH SIDES IS WHERE ARE YOU?
IT'S BAD ENOUGH THAT THEIR OWN
RHETORIC IS PUSHING SOME OF
THESE EXTREMISTS IN THAT
DIRECTION.
THEY SHOULD BE OUT ACTIVELY
TRYING TO TAMP THIS DOWN.
THEY SHOULD BE MAKING STATEMENTS
ABOUT RESPONSIBILITY, ABOUT TRUE
PATRIOTISM, NO MATTER HOW THEY
FEEL ABOUT WHATEVER
INVESTIGATION THEY'RE FIRED UP
ABOUT.
THERE'S NO -- ABSOLUTELY NO
EXCUSE FOR THIS SORT OF
PROVOCATION TO VIOLENCE.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE OUT TRYING TO
TAMP THIS DOWN.
>> ANDY McCABE, PHIL MUDD, OUR
THANKS TO BOTH OF YOU FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU DO.
JOIN US IS ARIA AND JOAN.
JOAN, YOU HEAR THIS STORY THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE OUT OF
OHIO.
DO YOU SEE THIS AS A ONE OFF?
OR DO YOU SEE THIS AS PART OF A
BROADER RADICALIZATION THAT YOU
SEE DOTS CONNECTED TO THE
RHETORIC THAT YOU'RE STUDYING?
>> YEAH.
SO, THERE'S A FEW THINGS GOING
ON HERE I THINK IN SOCIAL MEDIA
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS.
ONE OF THEM HAS TO DO CENTRALLY
WITH THE WAY IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE
POSTING ONLINE, ENCOURAGING ONE
ANOTHER.
THERE'S A LOT OF OVERT CALLS TO
VIOLENCE, JUST LIKE YOU
ADDRESSED.
AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
YEARS IS WHEN VIOLENT RHETORIC
ISN'T TAKEN DOWN AND CONTENT
ISN'T MODERATED THAT WE SEE THIS
WIRES TO THE WEEDS EFFECT WHERE
PEOPLE WILL EVENTUALLY COMMIT
THOSE VIOLENT ACTS.
WE HAVE SEEN IT WITH MESSAGE
BOARDS SUCH AS STORM FRONT WHERE
NEO-NAZIS USED TO GATHER OR
STILL DO.
AND NOW WE HAVE TO START LOOKING
MUCH MORE DEEPLY INTO TRUTH
SOCIAL.
I THINK ON THE -- IF THERE IS A
BRIGHT SIDE TO THIS, THIS
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ORGANIZED IN
THE SAME WAY THAT WE HAVE SEEN
OTHER KINDS OF VIOLENCE LIKE
JANUARY 6th.
AND SO, IN A SENSE, SHIFFER IS
BY NO MEANS A LONE WOLF, BUT
THIS WASN'T AN ORGANIZED ATTACK.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THAT
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT HE WAS
PART OF A MILITIA OR OTHER
GROUPS AT THIS STAGE.
AND SO, WE DO HAVE TO LOOK MUCH
DEEPER AT THE DATA IN THIS CASE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THE
SIGNS THAT WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE
WHERE SOMEONE POSTS ABOUT A
VIOLENT ACTIVITY AND THEN
CARRIES IT OUT SEEM TO TRACK
WITH SITES THAT HAVE LACK OF
SINCERE CONTENT MODERATION.
>> VERY, VERY IMPORTANT POINT
YOU'RE SEEING THAT TREND.
ARIA, YOU HAVE SEEN THE TONE
SHIFT, RIGHT, WITH THE RHETORIC.
>> YEP.
>> SINCE TRUMP LEFT OFFICE.
CAN YOU TELL US HOW?
>> WELL, WHILE TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE, MOST OF THE TALK INSIDE
YOU HAVE TO CALL IT MAGA WORLD,
THE PART OF THE ONLINE EXTREMISM
THAT WAS SUPPORTIVE OF TRUMP WAS
SOCIALLY PRO-GOVERNMENT IN ITS
ORIENTATION.
TRUMP WAS THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY SUPPORTED HIM.
AND THEY -- WHETHER THERE WAS
SUSPICION OF THE FBI OR OTHER
AUTHORITIES, WAS A SENSE THAT
ESSENTIALLY AS LONG AS TRUMP WAS
IN CHARGE, THINGS WOULD BE OKAY.
OBVIOUSLY AFTER JANUARY 6th,
AFTER THE INAUGURATION WHEN JOE
BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT, THERE
HAS BEEN A SHIFT.
WE'RE SEEING THE REEMERGENCE OF
PERHAPS A MORE CLASSIC,
CLASSICAL RIGHT WING
ANTI-GOVERNMENT EXTREMISM AND
THE DISCOURSE.
AND YOU KNOW, WHETHER THAT IS
AROUND COVID MEASURES, WHICH HAS
BEEN THE DOMINANT FORM OF RIGHT
WING ANTI-GOVERNMENT EXTREMISM
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF OR
SO, NOW COVID MEASURES HAVE KIND
OF LARGELY GONE.
THAT ENERGY IS BEING POURED INTO
OTHER AREAS.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE SEEING
IN PARTICULAR IS THE MAR-A-LAGO
SEARCH IS BEING A TRIGGER.
ANOTHER ONE, ODDLY ENOUGH, THESE
TWO ARE CONFLATED IN THE LAST
WEEK AND A HALF ON THE RIGHT IS
THE PLANS TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE IRS.
AND YOU'LL SEE THOSE TWO THINGS
SPOKEN ABOUT AS IF THEY'RE THE
SAME THING.
AS IF THIS IS ALL A PART, A PLAN
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
CLAMP DOWN ON PEOPLE LIKE US,
TRUMP FIRST AND THEN I GUESS ALL
OF HIS SUPPORTERS.